على نفس السياسه باقول اتفقا اعضاء اوبر
بلاس في اجتماعهم عبر تقنيه الفيديو على
الاستمرار في حصص انتاج النفط كما هي منذ
اكتوبر الماضي بالرغم من الحيره التي تسود
السوق والغضب الامريكيه الغربي من سياسات
التحالف النفطي ينص مسار منظمه الدول
المصدره للنفط وحلفائها بقياده روسيا الذي
اتخذ في اكتوبر الماضي على خفض الانتاج
بمقدار مليونير برميل في اليوم حتى نهايه
اكد بيانو اجتماعي
على القرار السابق اتخذ دعما للاسعار وجاء
فيه ان هذا الخط هو الواجب اتخذه لارسائل
الاستقرار في الاسواق
استراتيجيه التحالف النفقي وان لم تعجب
واشنطن ضروريه وفقا الدول الاعضاء عيون
الجميع ترقب الاوضاع في الصين فالبلد هو
المستورد الاول للنفط الخام في العالم وان
شيري تباطؤ اقتصادي او موجه جديده من
جائعات كورونا فيه سنعكس سلبا على الاسعار
ضرب ممثل اوبا بلوس موعدا لبعض اعضاء
التحالف في فبراير المقبل على ان يعقد
الاجتماع الوزاري الكامل في الثالثه
والرابع من يونيو العام المقبل الاجتماع
والافتراضي الذي انتهى بقرار متوقع الى حد
ما عقد في توقيت بالغ الحساسيه والتعقيدات
في الحرب الاخرى التي يشمها الغرب بقياده
الولايات المتحده على روسيا قرروا الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع واستراليا فرض
السقف على سعر النفط الخام الروسي
المنقولي بحرا عند الستين دولارا سيدخل
حيز التنفيذ الاثنين او بعد ذلك رده موسكو
على هذا الاجراء العقاب بالقول انها
لمتابعه نطقها بهذا السعر
واوضح نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي اليكساندر
نوفاك ان روسيا لم تعمل في ظل فرد حد اقصى
للسعر حتى لو اضطرت الى خفض الانتاج سلاحه
معاقبه مسك غير فعال بالنظر محليلين وبعض
اعضاء اوبك لان روسيا تبيع معظم نفقها الى
الصين والهند اللتين ترفضاني ادانه الحرب
في اوكرانيا ثم تتساؤل ممزوج بالخشيه يدور
بين الدول المصدره للنفط ماذا لو استخدم
الغرب في النهايه الاجراء نفسها ضد اي
منتج الحد الاقصى للسعر النفط الروسي كما
حدده حلفائك يبدو انه جعل مستوى الثقه بين
اوبك والغرب عند الحد الادنى هذه الايام